dans ce cimetière de Saint-Pétersbourg
des funérailles en catimini sans les
honneurs militaires pour éviter
de mercenaires du groupe Wagner et des
proches sont venus Vladimir Poutine lui
avait fait savoir qu'il n'y assisterait
pas
non loin du Kremlin à Moscou des
habitants se recueillent sur un mémorial
improvisé mais sans Wagner sur le front
les choses sont bien pires c'est pour ça
que nous sommes en deuil c'est une telle
perte
pour moi ils étaient des héros des
exemples pour le peuple russe qui se
sont sacrifiés pour leur pays
gaugine et 8 autres personnes ont été
tuées lors du crash de son avion il y a
une semaine le patron du groupe Wagner
est mort deux mois après sa rébellion
contre l'état-major malgré les soupçons
sur une éventuelle implication des
services russes le Kremlin agnait toute
idée de vengeance et démenti avoir
ordonné son assassinat Vladimir Poutine
a promis la semaine dernière que
l'enquête serait menée jusqu'au bout